again so i'm using your tweets as if
this is like plato all right
as if this is
well
thought out novels that you've written
uh you tweeted gpt4 is listening to us
now
um
this is one way of asking what are the
limitations of gpt3
when it scales so what do you think will
be the capabilities of gpt4 gpt5 and so
on what are the limits of this approach
so uh obviously when we are writing
things right now uh everything that we
are writing now is going to be training
data for the next generation of machine
learning models so yes of course tbt4 is
listening to us and i think the tweet is
already a little bit older and the uh we
now have wu dao and we have a number of
other systems that basically are
placeholders for gpt4 don't know what
open ais plans are in the city i read
that tweet
in several ways so one is obviously
everything you put on the internet is
used as training data
but
in the second way i read it is
in a uh
we talked about agency
i read it as almost like gpt4 is
intelligent enough
to be choosing to listen
so not only like did a programmer tell
it to collect this data and use it for
training i almost
saw the humorous angle which is like it
has achieved agi kind of thing well the
thing is um could we be already be
living in gpt5
[Laughter]
so gpt4 is listening and dpt5 actually
constructed the entirety of the so the
reality works we in some sense the what
everybody is trying to do right now in
ai is to extend the transformer to be
able to deal with video
and
there are very promising extensions
where there's a work by google that is
called perceiver
and that is uh
overcoming some of the limitations of
the transformer by letting it learn the
topology of the different modalities
separately
and
by
training it to find better input
features so the basic feature
abstractions that are being used by
uh this
successor or to gpt3 are chosen such a
way that it's able to deal with video
input
and there is more to be done so i one of
the limitations of gpt three is that
it's uh amnesiac so it forgets
everything beyond the two pages that it
currently reads also during generation
not just during learning
do you think that's fixable
within the space of deep learning can
you just make a bigger bigger bigger
input no uh i don't think that our own
uh working memory is infinitely large
it's probably also just a few thousand
bits
but uh what you can do is you can
structure this working memory so instead
of just
force feeding this thing a certain thing
that it has to focus on and it's not
allowed to focus on anything else with
its network
you allow it to construct its own
working memory as we do right when we
are reading a book
it's not that we are focusing our
attention in such a way that we can only
remember the current page
we will also try to remember other pages
and try to undo what we learned from
them or modify what we learned from them
we might get up and take another book
from the shelf we might go out and ask
somebody and we can
edit our working memory in any way that
is useful to put a context together
allows us to draw the right inferences
and to learn the right things
so this ability to perform experiments
on the world based on
an attempt to become fully coherent and
to achieve causal closure to achieve a
certain aesthetic of your modeling that
is something that eventually needs to be
done
and at the moment we are skirting this
in some sense by building systems that
are larger and faster so they can use
dramatically larger resources and human
beings can do much more training data to
get to models that in some sense are
already very superhuman and in other
ways are laughingly incoherent
so do you think uh sort of
making um the systems like what would
you say multi-resolutional so like
some
uh some of the language models are
focused on
two pages some are focused on
uh two books some are focused on
two years of reading some are focused on
a lifetime like so it's like stacks of
it's the gpt threes all the way down and
you want to have gaps in between them so
it's not necessarily two years there's
no gaps it's things out of two years or
out of twenty years or two thousand
years or two billion years yeah where
you are just selecting those bits that
are predicted to be the most useful ones
to understand what you're currently
doing and this prediction itself
requires a very complicated model that's
the actual model that you need to be
making it's not just that you are trying
to understand the relationships between
things but what you need to make
relationships or discover relationships
over
i wonder what that
thing looks like with the architecture
for that for the thing that's able to
have that kind of model that i think it
needs more degrees of freedom than the
current models have so it starts out
with the fact that you
possibly don't just want to have a feed
forward model
but you want it to be fully recurrent
and to make it fully recurrent you
probably need to loop it back into
itself and allow it to skip connections
once you do this
right when you are predicting the next
frame and your internal next frame
in every moment and you
are able to skip connection it means
that signals can travel
from the output of the uh network into
the middle of the network faster than
the inputs do you think it can still be
differentiable
do you think it still can be a neural
network uh sometimes it can and
sometimes it cannot so it uh it can
still be a neural network but not a
fully differentiable one and when you
want to deal with non-differentiable
ones you need to have an attention
system that is discrete and dual
dimensional and can perform grammatical
operations you need to be able to
perform program synthesis you need to be
able to backtrack in this operations
that you perform on this thing this
thing needs a model of what it's
currently doing and i think this is
exactly the purpose of our own
consciousness
yeah the program things are tricking
well in your networks
you